welcome everybody uh thanks to those who
are with us this morning and thanks to
those of you who may have joined us this
afternoon um I am Maria inhorn I'm a
professor of anthropology and
international Affairs here at Yale and
I'm also the outgoing editor of the
Journal of Middle East women's studies
and this as you may know is the 10th Ann
AR celebration of juse the Journal of
Middle East women's studies and it is
our annual celebration to have a a
conference of this type with a
distinguished lecturer and I am very
delighted that this year's distinguished
lecturer is Professor Sandra hail
because she has been absolutely part and
parcel of the development of jam M our
Journal over the past 10 years she was
co-editor of it as I'm going to say talk
about in a moment but she's been an icon
in Middle East um and Africa feminist
studies and so we're just really
delighted to have her with us at Yale
which is your first time at Yale is that
right yes yeah so welcome to
Sandra we're gonna call you Sandra she's
a close friend to of instead of
Professor hail sandre is is research
professor and professor amerita of
anthropology and women's studies at the
University of California Los Angeles
where she's had a very long history she
first earned her ba in English
literature at UCLA her ma in African
studies at UCLA and then her PhD in
anthropology after she received her PhD
she taught in a variety of Institutions
including the University of carum in
Sudan the California Institute of Arts
and the California state universities in
both Long Beach and Northridge but then
she returned to UCLA where she served as
professor of anthropology and women's
studies before her retirement two years
ago or two and a half years ago in 201
11 at UCLA she served in many capacities
as chair of women's studies which is now
called gender studies at UCLA she was
the co-chair of Islamic Studies and she
was the interim co-director of the
center for near Eastern studies and
during her tenure at the University she
helped to co-found the association of
Middle East women studies or amuse which
is the parent organization of juse and
then exactly a decade ago she and a
small group of feminist women uh really
wrote The Proposal wrote proposal to uh
get Jam use off the ground so she's just
been absolutely a critical player in the
development of the association in the
journal in terms of her research sandre
is a well-known scholar of Africa in the
Middle East she focuses mainly on the
Sudan and arria and she's the author of
I think what we call one of our classic
feminist ethnographies called gender
politics in Sudan islamism socialism and
the state which was first published in
1996 by Westview press which was later
translated into Arabic in 2011 and which
in my view provides really one of the
best analyses of the competing voices at
play in the sort of development and
continuance of the Sudanese feminist
movement in addition SRE published over
the years many articles and book
chapters on the topics of gender War
conflict and genocide International
gender studies including issues of
gender and citizenship diaspora studies
and cultural studies and social
movements including boycotts surrounding
issues of academic freedom her co-ed
volume called Sudan's Killing Fields is
going to be coming out this year and SRE
also is uh writes about feminist art I
know that you like the presentation this
morning on feminist art um and she has
recently published a co-edited volume
with Terry Wolverton called from sight
to Vision the wom's building in in
contemporary culture published in 2011
and it focuses on feminist art in Los
Angeles
area Beyond her many academic
contributions um I will throw in there
that sandre is a talented
ventriloquist
but but she's also a well-known activist
both domestically and internationally on
the domestic front she's carried out
activism on the various campuses where
she's taught including in the classrooms
where she's introduced new and
controversial ideas of many kinds she's
taken her graduate students with her
into protest movements is um a really
exemplary feminist activist for the
young uh women who has she has trained
over the years sandre is the founder and
coordinator of California Scholars for
academic freedom which is a coalition of
nearly 200 academics from 20
institutions of higher education in
California and she's been active for
decades in the civil rights movement in
anti-war movements and in feminist in
people of color movements her activism
Against Racism has really been a
significant component of her life and
she told me anecdotally that her mom in
deine Iowa where she grew up kind of in
a poorer part of the city um was very
concerned that every day Sandra befriend
and walk home with Children of color in
the community um so your mom was
basically a person of you know I don't
know what we call her an activist of her
own you know in her own way um so SRA
carries on these traditions of activism
and just sort of fighting for what's
right on the international stage she's
the founder and coordinator of the darur
task force and her support of sud
sudanes dissidence has out of
necessity been somewhat disguised but
it's an important area of her activism
so she has really been involved with
actually giving shelter and intellectual
homes to people coming from the Sudan
fleeing the Sudan who are activists and
she's been very very supportive of a you
know efforts in the Sudan in terms of
all forms of activism so sandre is the
recipient of numerous Awards and honors
and in addition to many teaching awards
that she's received in various
California institutions she received the
fair and open academic environment award
popularly known as the diversity award
at UCLA and she's been honored in a
variety of ways in various UCLA
departments twice she's been given an
award for courage from the community of
California State University Long Beach a
Vesta award for the Los Angeles women's
building of scholarship on the Arts and
numerous other Awards awards for her
service and in 2011 SRE received two of
her favorite awards first was a lifetime
scholarly Achievement Award from our
association of Middle East women studies
and then from the Salma Women's Center
Resource Center in carum Sudan she
received an award called in recognition
and appreciation of her 50 years of
commitment and valuable contributions in
support of the studes women's movement
um at the beginning of this year our
Journal juse published a special volume
volume 10 number one entitled scholar
Mentor activist sandre hail's
transnational feminist commitments it
was a beautiful it is a beautiful
special issue written put together by
mostly students and uh some colleagues
with wonderful contributions um not only
about Sudan but just the many areas of
gender scholarship um that sandre has
influenced others to do and I see some
of the authors here raise your hand we
have Ellen gromb and Anita Faba
and Susan simovich couldn't be here
andum and Aza couldn't be here but um
all many people who love and work with
sandre participated in that beautiful
special issue so look for it although
sandre is technically retired as of
November 1st
2011 she she was almost immediately
recalled to offer a graduate seminar at
UCLA and to co-direct the Center for
near Eastman
studies which she did for a while she
continues to carry out fieldwork and in
Sudan where she spent several weeks this
spring in cartoon and in you know
working in Sudan and to work on a number
of writing projects until she decides to
stop and her friends say this will never
happen um and she's not going to retire
basically sa's going to be active just
you're going to keep going forever I
believe until I'm drooling and they haul
me away anyway so she's a remarkable
person she's an icon of feminist
scholarship in the region of the Middle
East and in Africa and she's also just a
great supportive person very sagacious
very wise she's a person you can go to
to tell her your intellectual and
academic woses and she's no you're she's
a great person you know um we need to
have women mentors like this in our
academic and scholarly lives and so I
think we all really are grateful to you
for that Sandra and so with this I'd
like to give the stage to Professor
Sandra Hecla her distinguished lecture
of 2014 is entitled the new Middle East
insurrections and other subversions of
the modernist
frame I can't possibly live up to that
introduction of course which I did not
write I am quick to say um Marsha did
her did her homework she read several
documents I think thank you Marsha for
that wonderful uh introduction and I
also want to thank the sponsoring
organizations um J Muse and amuse and
the Council on Middle East studies here
at Yale and the McMillan Center for area
studies here at Yale um they've been
very generous with me and I've been very
well treated I want to uh thank the
staff um that made the trip and stay so
comfortable so far um I'm not especially
comfortable this moment but I have been
quite
comfortable um I want to thank Laura uh
and Amar and then when I I come to
Bonnie Rose and Mara I don't know where
to begin um Bonnie Rose is just the
bestest managing editor on the face of
the Earth and I've I've enjoyed not only
uh working with her academically and and
professionally but she's just been so
kind and wonderful to me a really uh
fantastic collegial person Mara has been
giving all the kudos to me and a couple
of other people in the room for for uh
juse but we really have an enormous debt
to pay to Mara because she was our very
first editor without her juse would not
have might not have made it you know how
difficult it is to start new journals
and uh so Marsha just took it and ran
for the first two years and built the
reputation that and Nancy Gallagher
who's somewhere here in the audience and
I took it then to and that was at
Michigan and then we took the journal
Jal to UCLA for 4 years and then Marsha
rescued us again um taking the journal
back to bringing the journal back to
Yale for four years so really Marsha too
much too much praise being given too
many other places and I really really
want to thank you uh good friend
also um but that's not why I'm saying
that no friendship has nothing to do
with
it um for more than a decade
I've been uh thinking about several
themes or topics that at first seemed
disperate uh but then I began to realize
that they were tangentially
related um maybe that's what you do when
you just can't get things straight in
your head and you're wondering you know
how you can can come up with any
coherence but at any rate for the last 3
years in
particular um coinciding with the
beginning of the so-called era
spring and uh by the way I I use um
italics all the way through for various
words uh but I'm not going to do my
little thing every time but uh since the
beginning of the Arab Spring and also
since the seccession of South Sudan from
Sudan in other words
2011 um I've been trying to put these
themes together or questions too not
just themes uh first in observing the
political Behavior of participants in
contemporary uprisings such as the
anarcho tinged Revolt in Seattle
Washington in
1999 against the international monetary
fund um since then I began to ask how
useful the modernist frame is for those
of us working on and for Revolution and
to ask the same question as hammed
deashi in his book the Arab Spring quote
to what extent is the notion of
Revolution appropriate in reading the
current uprisings in the Arab world and
do these revolutions perhaps posit and
purpose a new language for reading them
that Accords to them the Primacy of
authoring their own meaning end of quote
as an addendum I ask how useful those
grand narratives of emancipation such as
Marxism and feminism are I being both a
Marxist and a
feminist how relevant are other elements
of the Enlightenment such as the unity
of reason the unified subject uh order
and coherence the Reliance on science
and technology and the stress on social
and economic
progress in light of most postmodernist
thinkers dismissal of and disdain for
the concept of Revolution I began to
note a
paradox that elements of postmodernist
thinking and performance can be detected
in the Contemporary insurrections and
yet would we call them postmodernist
movements and
oxymoron in um in postmodern parlaments
I've tried to make sense of this
simultaneously I've been working on
knowledge production especially transn
knowledge feminist um knowledge
production and relating it to what I've
called migrating
epistemologies um then I began to
realize that one of the ingredients of
some of these uprisings is attempts to
dismantle the old regimes of knowledge
suggesting that the Journey of migrating
epistemologies within transnational
feminisms for example is
unsettled all along this journey I began
to leave a great deal of space in my
thinking for what Malcolm Gladwell
refers to as the gift of
uncertainty relatedly I grew to question
the concept of failure as it's generally
applied to development projects and
social movements and as some have
applied the term to the new
insurrections I began to see failure and
that definitely is in italics throughout
I began to see failure as being a queer
art uh to use Judith halberstam's
expression uh and is often having
unintended
consequences it is these unintended
consequences to which I devote an
important aspect of my
paper however one last variable has
graced my journey a revisit of my past
studies of public space especially
feminist use of public space here I've
also relied on Manuel castels who in his
analysis of the Contemporary
insurrections uses public space and
cyber space as reference and I've also
relied on a number of recent post um
Arab Spring writers who've stressed
public space or have gendered that
public space merup for example has has
some articles the latest mup this is
however the least developed idea in the
paper so I really I ran out of space and
time and everything else and wasn't able
to do much with um public space so maybe
some of you can can help push me along
in that area well let me um give us some
notes on postmodernism and
postcolonialism as I understand them
just so we're on the same general page
um I'm reviewing some of the ideas of
these late 20th and early 21st century
um conditions so that we can keep in our
mind some of the characteristics of the
new
insurrections so as we talk about
postmodernism I'd like you to think
about the own the insurrections that
you've been
following um and by the way we might
want to discuss these terms we've been
using I I will go back and forth between
Uprising
Insurrection I only use revolution when
I'm in italics
um and some other terminology that we
that terminologies that we might think
are even more
appropriate
um Pauline Rosenau says postmodernism
haunts social science
today as well as and I would add as well
as haunting or stalking our attempts to
analyze the new insurrections within a
modernist
framework uh roseno has reminded us that
postmodernist ideas challenge uh the
global all-encompassing World Views
reducing Marxism and feminism and
liberal democracy Etc to the same order
and she and and dismisses them all as
logocentric
transcendental totalizing metan
narratives wo what a
condemnation logocentric transcendental
totalizing metan narratives that
anticipate all questions and provide
predetermined
answers therefore modernist social
movements mainly based on identity unity
and a central truth with a capital T
have no
legitimacy besides their thought to be
te logical suggesting a moral end alant
terrain and others argue that quote
modernity is no longer a force for
Liberation it is rather a source of
subjugation oppression and
repression the postmodernist goal is to
delegitimate all delegitimate all master
codes
some postmodernist theorists like Bowman
even invite us to be comfortable in the
absence of certainty and explanation and
to accept the new philosophical
relativism some offer renewed relevance
to the traditional the sacred the
particular and the irrational terrain
for example in fact according to roseno
citing Gerald
graph um all that Mo all that modernity
has set aside a reject rejected has
taken on renewed importance in
postmodernist thinking emotions feelings
intuition reflection speculation
personal experience custom metaphysics
tradition cosmology myth magic religious
sentiment a mystical experience well
that sounds like a feminist soap opera
but these are these are all elements
that those of us in the social science
Sciences who were trained in is at least
initially in positivism we're told to
absolutely eliminate from our from our
research uh the fact that some of those
have crept back into our research is no
doubt a
positive ruso claims that postmodernists
offer indeterminacy rather than
determinism relativism rather than
objectivity diversity rather than Unity
difference rather than synthesis
complexity rather than
simplification and look to the unique
rather than to the
general uh
furthermore not only is there no Central
truth but the idea of centering man with
a capital m has been
undermined in fact there's no unitary
subject no universalism and
fragmentation is preferred to
totalization all of which means that
truth gives way to
tentativeness uh amounting to the
demolition of most of the ideas from the
enlightenment including cluding the
notion of
Reason relevant to our U topic of the
new insurrections are the substitutes
that postmodernists and postcolonial
thinkers have slotted in as their chosen
qualities of social life for example
playfulness word games performativity
and
creativity a trickier term to deal with
is postc
colonialism and I'm wondering if I want
to uh skip this whole section on
postcolonialism uh in which I remind us
of what we're bringing in from um not
just Edward s's orientalism but um
discourse theory in general I mean s s
used Fuko homi Baba used alus and Lan uh
SPAC used dereda Etc and just to remind
us about some of these postmodernist
thinkers uh postcolonial thinkers and
also um to remind us that um that there
was there's a great deal of stress on
language as as dominant as as dominating
and is colonial discourse and what
colonial discourse means and so on um
and this whole idea of dismantling the
old regimes of knowledge that we're
seeing in the new Insurrection strike me
as examples of a negation of
mimicry uh although ambivalence is very
much a part of what we're
seeing I have not worked out this area
of postcolonial thought and the
insurrections I'm still working on it um
also a part that I'm skipping is this
other Milestone of postcolonial thought
which is the uh subaltern
theorists um but as I said I'm going to
run out of time if if I if I deal with
them I think most people in the room
have read hom Baba and or many people at
least um as a general statement we could
say that post Colonial studies is the
process of interrogating the center from
the margin using
deconstruction but how useful are these
ideas in looking at the new
insurrections well let me talk about the
feminisms and our discontent our
discontents plural both of them
plural uh because the amalgam of
postmodernism postcolonialism and
transnational feminisms has for some
time offered us ideas that are open
contingent overlapping fluid diverse
differentiated and ambiguous it seems
fitting to mention here some of the
ideas within transnational feminisms in
addition to gesturing towards the new
insurrections as a source for some of
our more recent ideas and
actions in considering political
Behavior the amalgam I just
mentioned uh quite an amalgam by the way
I mean to throw postmodernism
postcolonialism trans feminism
transnational feminism and so on all
together as if it's one thing with which
you're going to move forward is um a bit
fool hearty but you know um give me a
chance
um in considering political Behavior the
amalgam I just mentioned has had a
profound effect on my thinking in
general I'm influenced by post 1980s
feminisms and critical race theories
meaning among other approaches I try try
not to essentialize or totalize anything
you probably catch me in that I'm also
becoming less exact and less explicit
and leaving space for the
plurals likewise it's too limiting as a
method or a thought to spell things out
completely um to Define them too closely
or to try to fix them in space or time
or
approach although many femin feminisms
come out of modernism or have been a
part of modernity
I think that it's important to subvert
the rigidity of modernism that may
categorize feminism as a unitary system
instead it seems more useful and
relevant to interpret phenomena as not
closed definite or finite and not
rigidly defined or categorized slippery
stuff I also try to avoid the pitfalls
of naturalizing categories Concepts or
subjects for example I don't deal with
identities
as identity per se but as critical
perspectives ways of looking at the
world critically from a particular from
a particular perspective that is ways of
analyzing it is as we are perceiving so
being a
Latina uh or a Sudanese then is not so
much an identity even though it may get
expressed that way as it is a critical
perspective or viewing a film as a queer
spectator perhaps most importantly with
regard to the feminisms I'm convinced
that a theory or a critical perspective
requires actually insists on or
generates a practice or prais here is
where the feminisms offer a challenge to
many of the post-modernist precepts I've
laid out which would appear on the
surface anyway not to insist on a
practice however there Remains the
problem of how to put our less than
finite and flexible Notions into
practice in feminism Without Borders
decolonizing Theory practicing
solidarity which probably most of you
have read Shandra mahanti calls for us
to recognize and put into practice a new
ethics a rethinking of self and
community Through the practice of
emancipatory Education a rethinking of
the workings of power and strategies of
resistance in both Grassroots movements
and academic
institutions finally she calls for
theorizing and practicing and anti-
capitalist and Democratic critique and
education and through Collective
struggles Ella shot and talking Visions
Multicultural feminism in a
transnational age suggests we try to
practice Multicultural feminisms that
when I first read that it made my head
spin couldn't imagine it practicing
Multicultural feminisms and then she
says quote not in the simple additive
sense of many histories and geographies
but as a political and cultural project
which mobilizes the polycentric
relationality of a constantly changing
world end of quote and I would add a
transnational
World many aspects of postmodernist
thought may give us pause with regard to
the relationship to the feminisms in
general the feminisms don't fit neatly
into either modernism or
postmodernism that is the kinds of
feminisms that I generally U think about
partially because there are elements of
both and there are contradictions and
there are dialectical processes and
imbrications that subvert um aspects of
various
feminisms for
example I hope I'm not putting you to
sleep with these abstractions I get to
much more um grounded uh ideas in a in a
moment in about actually about 85 Pages
I'll reach the uh
the the more concrete let's put it that
way um for example some postmodernist
and
postcolonial Colonial thinkers call for
a refocusing on that which has been
taken for granted has been neglected
forgotten considered irrational I'm into
one of those lists again has been seen
as insignificant or repressed has been
deemed
borderline the sacred traditional
eccentric sublimated rejected
non-essential marginal excluded tenuous
silenced accidental it's great fun to
dwell in all of those certainly many
feminist Scholars have rescued and
reinstated and resuscitated many of
these ideas and methods I think we were
way ahead in that regard for example for
some decades many feminist Scholars have
focused on the esoteria minutia and
ordinariness of life for example diary
recordings gen gen genealogies recorded
in a family bible messages and symbols
sewn into a quilt Etc nothing is too
insignificant when trying to reconstruct
a life or a subjectivity a voice which
is a term we'll problematize in a
moment uh there are other relevant
themes and transnational postcolonial
Multicultural feminisms that should be
familiar to many first we try to disrupt
conventional dichotomies such as
oppressor and oppressed
all concept two all concepts are subject
to
deconstruction re-evaluation subversion
and intervention three we use language
to unsettle but we also try to unsettle
language four furthermore we can no
longer assume a simple voice in italics
that is minimal units of
self-de according to shohat quote
Multicultural feminism avoids the twin
pitfalls of an atomized fracturing of
units of the local on whose behalf I
truly speak on the one hand and a defuse
all embracing Cosmopolitan
internationalism which speaks for all of
us on the other hand one way to shed
some light on the ways in which we can
see the feminisms within the prism of
postmodernism and
postcolonialism is to discuss
transnational
feminisms in fairly recent years which
I'm not going to do a great deal by the
way which is why I took it out of the
original
title um in fairly recent years we've
begun to analyze the movement of bodies
goods and ideas across National
boundaries such that restrict the such
that strict uh distinctions among
nations become altered or more
flexible uh such movement hybridity and
ambiguity create an unsettled
environment for identity
politics casting aside identity politics
has opened the door for the kinds of
collective actions we've seen since 1999
and more strikingly since
2011 I'm have entitled this next section
uncertainty in the new uprisings aha
we're getting to the
point these uh postmodernist and
postcolonial ideas have had the effect
of unsettling many of my ideas and
causing me to re-evaluate aspects of my
research area the Middle East and Africa
specific Al Sudan in my studies of
women's and people's movements over
several
decades um I had always worked within a
modernist mode I didn't see how we could
work in any other way I claimed that
postmodernist ideas do not lead us to
Liberation nationalism in the case of
some postcolonial thought perhaps but
not
Liberation even many approaches to
transnational feminisms did not seem to
leave room for emancipatory practice for
example the really wonderful pioneering
book by graell and
Kaplan um and we feminist and others
have had a very limited definition of
what it means to be
revolutionary Scholars of women's
movements have defined a movement as
contrasted to rebellions riots
spontaneous and Collective actions Etc
um have defined uh movement in
particular ways that place movement as a
very
is very much a part of modernity for
example Janet shavitz and Gary dworin in
a book called female revolts lay out
conditions for particular political
actions to be considered a women's
movement um they insist that there has
to be a span of years that there has to
be a large number of
supporters that there has to be a
network of
organizations and there has to be a
unifying theme and there has to to be
leadership I believed all that in other
words these are movements which are also
hierarchical this fairly commonly
received conception of a movement or a
women's movement simply doesn't fit what
we're seeing today in most of the new
insurrections because I've always worked
within a modernist frame I had to
theorize that Revolution can happen only
if we have a clear agenda that is agreed
on by all of us only if we're unified
even if it's just a loose uh Coalition
of groups and only if we mobilize make
demands and deny
failure we had to be firmly and
unflinchingly committed to the cause
failure was not possible a much
expressed slogan in our modernist
movements failure is not
possible however thanks to a number of
recent authors most coming from Fields
different from from my own I've be I've
been given the gift of doubt and that
comes from Malcolm Gladwell in a New
Yorker article one of those times when
you say
aha leading me to look at the
Contemporary insurrections the Middle
East Africa gender politics and the
world in a very different
light I'm referring to the anarcho
Tendencies and direct democracy actions
that we're seeing in some of the
collective actions of the last decade or
so for example to name them again the
anti- capitalist anarcho tinged um
revolt against the
WTA in Seattle various Environmental
Green movements the Occupy movements
sedan's GNA which means we're fed up boy
are we Egypt's kafaya meaning enough
movement
Spain's indignados or
indas uh indignant ones uh Iceland's
kitchen wear
Revolution the Arab Spring insurrections
of Tunisia Egypt and libia the actions
emanating from toxim Square gazi Park
and Istanbul and in various squares in
Greater carum
Sudan I use only some of these examples
to discuss the use of experimental Str
strategies and new formations and
associations which I see as
manifestations of post post modern or
postc Colonial and feminist
strategies it seems an appropriate place
to say that when I thought of the term
distinguished lecture it you know it's a
a little daunting but then I thought
this is an experimental paper is one so
foolish as to give an experimental paper
and call it a distinguished or have it
called a distinguished lecture well
anyway here we
go I've argued elsewhere that despite
the reject ction and dismissal of
modernist social movements by many
postmodern postmodernist and
postcolonial thinkers I was going to use
Pomo Poco and it was because it was a
distinguished lecture that I didn't feel
I could say Pomo Poco so uh there we go
um the dismissal uh of modernist social
movements by many Pomo and Poco thinkers
we can see tendencies in recent
political actions that indicate that
political actors in including some
transnational feminists in the Vanguard
are doing a whole new politics that does
not mimic the characteristics of
modernity they are anti-statism
anti-authority and opposed to
hierarchical organization they are all
searching for new and Freer forms of
Association that have already had and
will continue to have a profound effect
on gender
dynamics that at least um also that at
least half of these new insurrections
are taking place in the Middle East and
North Africa raises a number of other
interesting questions mainly about our
assumptions even Among Us Mena
Specialists I mention I mentioned that
most of these insurrections undermine
conventional ways of acting in quote
revolutionary movements not only are
different language forms and non-verbal
Behavior such as hand signals used but a
number of the Contemporary actions can
be characterized as having a playful
and creative aspect to them often in the
form of
performance and I I just think about
what it was like uh in the 60s when I
was trying to find a home for my
Marxism uh attending various leftist
parties but the Communist Party in
particular was
stultifying
humorless uh unbelievably
boring and as were most of the the the
parties that I that I visited during my
independent Marxist period I'm still an
independent
Marxist um sedan's political and Bender
Collective uh girifna for example used
flash demonstrations and Guerilla
theater occupying public space and
exiting before the authorities could
reach them raising Consciousness on the
run so to speak likewise Egypt's kafaya
uh used sarcastic and biting humor in
their public public performance of
opposition uh to Politics as
Usual we can see the humor even in the
names that they've chosen for their
organizations I mean instead of you know
the Communist Party of Sudan we we get
we are fed up and in the case of Egypt
enough uh not to mention the humorous
graffiti slogans in Egypt it's not only
language that's being creative but also
the choices of public and private places
and spaces
on which these words or phrases are are
placed um I love Karima khalil's edited
compilation uh it was published by Au
called um messages from taher signs from
Egypt's Revolution published in
2011 um this volume presents a number of
illustrations for example people have
used their bodies for political
self-expression I don't mean this is the
first time this has ever been done but
it's been done more fre quently in these
new
insurrections um for example a message
from Mubarak in his regime quote you
will leave by the hands of the youth
written on the hands of the youth um
just you know an enormous amount of of
of cleverness and sarcasm and so on or
car license plates with the command
leave on them uh or a barcode with
Mubarak and an exper date um or a kite
flying
um that says leave Mubarak on it or
intentionally misspelling mubarak's name
on a makeshift sign the slogans have
been sometimes hilarious with that
famous Egyptian sarcasm for example
quote I'm desperate it's been almost a
week since I've had tear
gas um the performances have been
Innovative for example a man dressed in
a football referee outfit holding a
whistle or holding a whistle in his
mouth and a red card saying Mubarak out
um in general the use of of different
language to describe one's political
opposition is indicative of the current
youth movements it's difficult to move
into an era of free association if one
is using old language and old visual
symbols suggestive of old structures as
we know various forms of feminism have
also experimented with new language as
have some schools of thought within
postmodernism and post
colonialism the sense of humor is so in
contrast to the political parties of
modernity the notion of over serious
commentary and oppositional political
actions has been superseded by humor and
playfulness even though people are
getting arrested and killed in some
instances and so on um humor has pretty
much prevailed some of you can maybe
correct me on what's going on in some of
these places now Manuel castels refers
us to Iceland's kitchen wear uh
Revolution which followed the 2008
economic
meltdown the populist public displays
were were named kitchen wear in other
word were were named for pots and pans
that were used sorry pots and pans were
used to express outrage and also to be
inclusive of everyone the noisy and
messy pots and pans performance not only
could rally people but symbolized the
common people and common and everyday
activities human dignity would seem to
be a major theme performed in these
current insurrections thereby not only
personalizing the political activity but
encouraging
self-reflexivity in many cases also uh
referencing gender Dynamics Diane
singerman for example um in an article
in a recent article in
J discusses the importance of dignity in
the Egyptian uprising
with special reference to women in Spain
the
indignados um IND
indas is a self-reflexive movement that
stresses process over product
reminiscent of of the
feminisms uh that was one of the slogans
that I heard in early in early 1970s
feminism in the United States uh the
process was more important than the
product um castel's described the
describes the shared terms of discourse
in the indignado movement some of the
terms and principles that the indignados
are used were self-management of
community a nonlinear process of
decision making a respect for all ideas
and that meant no
voting I mean that one is just really
very
striking um to to think of voting as not
respecting other people's opinions was
head spinning for me really a futurist
condition in other words the right now
is stressed no bosses
non-representational so direct democracy
you don't do it through through a
representative nonviolence
decommodification they didn't use any
money creativity and slowness you know
we'll we'll get there wherever there is
there may not be any there there but
we'll get there
slowly as for North America one of the
most successful insurrections of recent
years is one that I experienced directly
the Occupy Movement beginning with the
Occupy Wall Street movement originating
in New York but with its geographically
widespread
manifestations it describes itself on
its open source uh website as leaderless
non-violent resistance movement that's
highly
diverse their website announces that we
are the 99% a slogan that became very
contagious as virtually everyone could
identify with it uh it's revealing that
they also claim to be using the tactic
tactics of what they call the
Revolutionary Arab Spring so there's a
lot of contagion in these movements in
most of the Occupy movements decisions
are made in the general assembly which
castel's describes as horizontal
leaderless and census-based open meeting
that uses hand signals partially as fun
and
self-expression partially to replace
technology a paradox that I observed is
that although much has been made of
these political actions being internet
and social media Revolutions a parallel
stream is a rejection of technology and
of the capitalism that propels it this
is an aspect of these movements that
coincides with some postmodern
postcolonial ideas and I haven't uh
looked at these insurrections uh closely
enough or long enough to be able to see
if there is a big contradiction between
the embracing of Technology the social
media and the rejecting uh rejection of
Technology maybe some of you can try to
clarify that a bit the Occupy Movement
developed into fragments not branches or
cells but fragments I found the Occupy
UCLA movement a fragment of the larger
movement it was very highly diverse with
women playing a major role it was
self-reflexive and deeply mutually
respectful again with dignity being a
respected mode of behavior I found my
colleagues and it more interested in
building new forms of Association than
in making demands in other words
enjoying being with each other and the
processes that exist in such an
environment castels discusses these no
demand movements that use slogans like
the process is the
message now these organiz ations or
disorganizations which are primarily
composed of Youth and women are not
Guided by a central Truth by which
people must abide there's no unitary
subject in other words there's the
absence of a meta narrative or master
code I also observed a high degree of
uncertainty which does not seem to
perplex them nor does not having a clear
direction or a Unity certainly not a
Unity of ideology from what I learned
directly from the Occupy Movement
participants seem comfortable with the
fragmentation and ambiguity that Reigns
people did not seem to force the notion
that they must stay together to
Eternity these are open contingent
overlapping and fluid
actions I stood on the margins of one of
the liveliest and most uh in quotes
successful insurrections in the sense
that the spirit of the Insurrection was
building up while I was in a hotel
overlooking tuim Square in the heart of
Istanbul which as we know itself
occupies an ambiguous location between
Europe and Asia filled with daily often
political activity I witnessed it in
2013 as a chaotic fastmm moving modest
square with a small Park as a park which
became the center of an uprising to save
it from development all of you know the
story because toxine was already
associated with daily
demonstrations social media was not so
not such a necessary tool for
congregating people as a journalist
remarked uh quote revolutions happen in
the flesh in taxim strangers have
discovered one another their common
concerns and Collective voice the power
of bodies coming together at least for
the moment has produced a democratic uh
moment end of quote participants made
very moving statements about the
experience of being in the square one
woman part participant remarked we found
ourselves in this undertaking the
protesters of toxim gazi are engaging in
a fluid irregular open and unpredictable
set of actions manifesting postmodern
and feminist ideals as a thorn in the
side of Istanbul's
modernity the demonstrations morphed and
spread out into other parks where
families and others have been holding
nightly or weekly forums again not
referring to themselves as a movement or
giving themselves a name but relaxing
into the area of
uncertainty the participants in these
insurrections also take pride in the
decentralized and even fragmented nature
of their permeable movements making
claims that quote toxim is everywhere
and using slogans such as occupy is
everywhere the messiness of the
insurrections we've witnessed in the
last few years have caused some to think
of them as failures in
italics initially I was unimpressed with
the seeming direction of the uprisings
aligning my thinking more with the
pessimists but then I read this article
in the New Yorker by Malcolm Gladwell
entitled The Gift of Doubt not even
remotely connected with the
insurrections and not the kind of
reading I would ordinarily do I must
have been desperate that night no no
crime know no to read or mystery
novel Gladwell is reviewing a biography
of um a man named herschman Albert hman
who's was an economist and urban
planner uh so Gladwell became kind of
his
proxy and they the two of them
inadvertently offered me words to
describe so some of what I've been
thinking about the Arab Spring and toxim
and would eventually think about the
2013 Sudan
Uprising in the principle of the hiding
hand the name of an essay by Hershman he
was drawn to the many ways in which
plans did not turn out the way they're
supposed to the unintended consequences
and perverse outcomes and the puzzling
fact that the shortest line between two
points is often a dead
end hman was also Keen to say that
language itself is revealing and in my
view as I said earlier it's a part of
what is so different about these new
politic itical actions the next section
of the paper I entitled the concept of
failure and its unintended consequences
some ideas from greater carum I just
came back from cartoom on March 1st so
you can tell how well digested these
ideas are they really new to
me uh I'm hoping that uh some couple of
the sanist and one Sudanese in the
audience will be able to uh shed some
light on on this
on November 7th well my first line
doesn't have to do with sedan it has to
do with Egypt on November 7th 2013 Ahmed
Maher one of the youth leaders of the
April 6th segment of the Egyptian
Uprising gave a talk at
UCLA in which he referred to their
Uprising as a
failure which just and then he said uh
we'll just have to start all over again
at the time I was St startled that he
could possibly think that their
political actions had failed when the
whole world took notice and people were
changed as a result of their
actions I mean I knew what he meant but
I was rejecting this idea of
failure here's where I turn return to
one of my main
points um looking at Sudan's seeming
false starts the supposed scattering of
the opposition and the like I want to
underscore the importance of uncertainty
and making creative Ventures out of
mistakes or
failures this has been a turbulent time
for sedan uh someone probably needs to
tell me how we're doing on
time
okay but what about my 85
pages we at just leave
some
minut you mean if I just continue to
talk no one will challenge me and just
use up the
time okay um this has been a turbulent
time for
sedan a country so invisible to most of
the world that experiments can take
place and fail without having to be
under the constant gaze of world opinion
as Egypt has been women can play major
roles without the West especially
Western feminist anointing them and
patronizing them by commenting on their
progress within the last three years
sedan the northern part of which often
identified as Arab lost a part of itself
with the secession of African identified
South
Sudan and as one of many consequences
took an economic
dive sudanes witnessed the government
bombing the Numa mountains composed of a
series of non-arab ethnic groups in the
west central part of the
country and people also experienced a
massive flood in the Capital Area then
in September 2013 people carried out
bloody oppositional acts in an attempt
to uproot the military islamist
government or at least and this is an
important distinction to unsettle it
furthermore in 2013 2014 14 women were
acting in an oppositional mode and I
discuss this in a moment people were
taking big chances engaging in direct
Democratic actions and flirting with
danger life could not have been less
certain and everyone I talked with
mentioned being depressed because
September had
failed yet these various failures had
unintended consequences uh let me relate
uh a few of them I'm hoping some people
might be able to add to them in 2009 a
local Sudanese representative of India's
Barefoot College um gak Kadota managed
to persuade Indian and Sudanese
authorities to include women from the
remote and economically marginalized
area of the nuba mountains in a project
to train women as solar Engineers quite
a revolutionary thought the women were
given six months of training in India
with the aim of electrifying villages in
the nuba mountains
and training others to do the
same the women who were selected had to
be older so that the chances that they
would leave their Villages would be less
and they had to be uneducated formally
uneducated so that their local education
would not interfere in their absorbing
the whole new experience of the Barefoot
College four nuba women had their
training and returned to Hopeful
celebrations shortly after the first
Village in the nuba mountains was
electrified and it was really
electrifying however in June 2011 before
the next Village could be electrified
the government bombed the nuba mountains
and War
began the precious solar panels and
installations were destroyed the project
had failed two of the women fled to the
capital as many thousands did and joined
the ranks of the internally displaced
person the situation was very difficult
for these idps they had no income the
children could not be schooled and the
environment and government were hostile
in 2012 Dr Kadota again persuaded the
authorities to allow the women to return
to India for further or follow-up
training in the production of various
Goods which they'd never done before
with the aim of adding to some of the
skills they had developed in their first
training in the Barefoot College the
making of candles sanitary pads chalk
paper bags and toys it was decided by
the group of by a group of nuba with the
help of Kadota and others that the women
would develop an income generated
Factory backstopped by a Cooperative uh
which was officially registered in
2014 uh no minor task to get registered
with the Sudanese government um all of
these were enormous accomplishments
these were clearly unintended
consequences of a war the recuperation
of women's abilities in the face of
seeming uh
failure in 2013
greater carum experienced a massive
flood that destroyed the humble
dwellings of thousands of people perhaps
a result of the abandonment of any
welfare role of the government youth uh
resurrected the Sudanese social custom
of the nafir a called IM mobilize the
tradition of volunteering during a
crisis which is still practiced in in
some of rural Sudan this most recent
example of nafir was a response to the
2013 flood crisis
uh that resulted in the in the loss of
many lives and as I said homes many
youth I spoke with insisted this coming
together materialized into a youth
movement and is still expanding ready to
respond to any crisis and is being
politicized the nefir had never been a
political organization type organization
the emergence of a youth movement was
another unintended consequence this time
of a
flood in general the last few years
political actors especially Youth and
women have experienced a number of
setbacks as the government fearing
rebellions over neoliberal and austerity
measures put into effect as a response
to the loss of oil Revenue became more
repressive closing newspapers raiding
NGO headquarters Closing Centers on the
left arresting human rights activists
driving groups such as girifna
underground and the
like among the anti unanticipated
consequen quences has been the pro a
process whereby groups have moved into
different and creative modes of
political expression for example while
ngos suffered considerable funding
cutbacks over the last two years some
are making use of local resources to
continue their
activities also as Government security
became increasingly stifling um of of
angry protests women and others began to
respond with upbeat and optimistic
semi-public performances one example is
the cartoom rising event um that one can
see on on YouTube uh in February 2013
organized by Salma Women's Resource
Center an NGO in collaboration with
other civil society and youth groups it
was an example of a low-key yet
far-reaching event the organizers staged
a happy dance of Freedom by hundreds of
young and older women at afide
University for women it was videotaped
and sent um
viral on the on the YouTube The
Association of the words rising and
spring did not go unnoticed perhaps a
quiet announcement of Sudan's entry into
the insurrections of contemporary times
but certainly an unintended consequence
of the increased
repression the following year 2014 while
I was there the same organizations
organized a larger event this one called
1 billion Rising against violence
against women that grew in numbers of
participants uh demonstrated Bolder
activities and expanded into other
cities the event I attended was held at
aide University for women private
university venue but with public
exposure it was filled with security
people in September
2013 a series of large demonstrations
were carried out consisting of
Representatives of many groups but not
led by any group in particular and
certainly not led by the old political
parties so this was a big change I don't
mean they weren't participating but they
weren't leading it the composition was
decidedly young with a large proportion
of women these events were held in
public spaces two main squares uh one in
cartoon Hera Freedom Square uh and one
in uh Cartoon
north um my interviews in carum after
the September two 2013 demonstrations
and overlapping into October among youth
reveals several ambivalent and ambiguous
attitudes a number said that the
demonstrations had failed meaning failed
to overthrow the government and yet some
of the same people admitted that the
demonstrations were not necessarily
aimed at overthrowing the government but
that they just wanted to make their
voices heard in my group interview with
uh four members of girifna they agreed
among themselves that the demonstrations
were held precipitously and that the
people should have laid the groundwork
that was a fairly common criticism I
brought up the idea of U false
consciousness using that very carefully
about failure and they agreed that the
political liveliness and Defiance that
is in in quotes in the air in Greater
cartoon would point to a raised
Consciousness about the political
future my experience in my nearly two
months in cartoon January through
February of this year was that people
were far more creative in their thinking
than I had ever experienced in Sudan and
more
defiant yes Sudan had two civilian
overthrows of military governments in
1964 and 1985
true but those were so very different so
qualitatively different from what we
what one could see in in
2013 so on the one hand they could say
that they were very depressed over the
failure of September on the other hand
they were willing to make Danger ous
statements in public settings all the
while knowing that security agents were
ubiquitous this was a major change in
the public Persona from all of my
previous visits since n since 2004 an un
unintended consequence of failure I
would
posit greater cartoon may not be
experiencing an Arab Spring although
that metaphor was evoked frequently
across the Spectra of those I
interviewed but many of the same process
are taking place that we see elsewhere
women in Youth and their fragmented and
and diverse
anarchic Democratic leaderless and
creative groupings are forging a whole
new set of ways to come together to
experiment for the future or even not
for the future one young woman remarked
to me that the authoritarian islamist
military government of Omar Basher quote
could stay in power I don't care I will
just go go on doing what I'm doing here
on the ground working to change things
change everything about this life that
we're being forced to lead end of quote
another woman demonstrator wearing
tightly wearing a tightly wrapped hijab
gestured towards her friend sitting a
few seats away the friend was dressed in
tight jeans and top with no head
covering the first woman remarked that
the two of them who had not known each
other before had been arrested together
during the demonstrations and had become
friends in jail nothing like
jailed get people
together she remarked that she realized
that a demonstration would not in the
tyranny of the state instead she claimed
that what the demonstrations highlighted
for her was that they had to start with
their own families and rais
Consciousness about women and
patriarchy both women said they'd never
attended a demonstration before and that
being arrested changed their
Consciousness most of the women in the
room who were discussing events with me
had not attended a demonstration before
September 2013 but said they were all
aroused politically after the events and
vowed to work on change at a Grassroots
level perhaps some of these processes
don't seem like unintended consequences
we all know that demonstrations can
raise Consciousness but what has
impressed me about the September events
is that people are still talking about
them uh but they're moving into
different territory with their thoughts
PE women and particular are now focusing
more on gender Dynamics convinced of the
Need For Change there first and then
move on let me uh conclude as quickly as
I
can short
conclusion in the introduction I quoted
hammed dubashi question to what extent
is the notion of Revolution appropriate
in reading the current uprisings in the
Arab
world for many especially members of of
established oppositional political
parties revolutionary Revolution was
their aim but for most of the young
participants the goals included doing a
whole new politics that does not mimic
the characteristics of modernity to
repeat what I said above these
participants in the uprisings have in
common a belief that their political
actions are anti-statism
anti-authority and opposed to hierarchy
hierarchical
organization they're all searching for
new and Freer forms Ms of Association
that have already had and will continue
to have an effect on gender Dynamics if
missteps delays and
miscalculations can eventually Propel
someone or something into forms of
success or at least unintended
consequences then we should look at
these more
closely also we western or Western
trained observers often want to see
change come quickly when some of the
current insurrections for example of her
heralded slowness is a
virtue we also tend to want to see a
wholeness or a total Revolution as do
some of the participants we're far too
quick to deem something a failure
because people do not agree on one
course of action do not have a clear
ideology and are fragmented and
inconsistent or Egyptians lament that
yes they overthrew a dictator but failed
to change the entire oligarchic
patriarchal authoritarian
regime we're seeing the fits and starts
of a messy series of events but the fact
that many of the participants continue
to be self-reflexive and subversive
seems highly important for now a
building block if if you will in
discussing the queer art of failure
Judith halberton points to quote a basic
desire to live life otherwise a quest to
articulate an alternative vision of life
love and labor and to put such a vision
into practice through manifestos a range
of political tactics and new
technologies of representation radical
utopians continue to search for
different ways of being in the world and
being in relation to one another end of
quote halberton asks what kinds of
reward failure can offer us using ideas
from Barbara Aron reich's bright sided
Alber notes that although fail comes
accompanied by a host of negative
affects such as disappointment
disillusionment and
despair it also provides an opportunity
to use these negative effects to poke
holes in the toxic P posivity of
contemporary life Albert Stam also
points to some of the ideas of James
Scott's seeing like a state how certain
schemes to improve The Human Condition
have failed she uses his ideas to
express Express a favorable view of
borrowing from European Anarchist
thought or practical forms of knowledge
that he calls metis and that emphasize
mutuality collectivity plasticity
diversity and
adaptability she uses failure as a form
of unbeing and Unbecoming giving us a
new relationship to knowledge or
subverting the regimes of knowledge in
analyzing the Arab Spring deashi has
opted for the idea of open-ended
revolutions
and work in progress with regard to
Sudanese activists who are clearly
engaged in a work in progress one that
is fluid contingent irregular open
unpredictable and uncertain please stand
up and be counted thank
you that was amazing and you know such a
hopeful ending too about the fact that
these really aren't fa failures these
are just in a way the beginning of a new
you know period
of unexpected things to come we can't
tell what the future holds but um
hopefully as you said people are
striving for better lives and and better
things to come so we do have time for
some questions and thoughts and comments
and I guess I will call on people and
can you say who you are and where you
from New York I would like to know if I
can ask a question that's not related to
your talk I don't
know I'd like to know if you have a
position in regard to the debate or the
controversy in France regarding the
teaching in the gender in public
schools
well of course I have a position and
that is that we should be teaching
gender in public
schools um did you have
something
youens egpt the mle E Sudan
and controversy started
with the controversy started uh not not
only with the extreme right especially
with the Christian conservatives but
mainly with the conservative Muslim
friends so i' would like to know if you
have any position or any
explanations I know it's not related um
can we talk afterwards
okay maybe he's not a gentleman we don't
know
yet I I hope I am a gentleman okay uh uh
yes uh JF G say uh I'm originally from
from Turkey actually and I've been
actually I'm well I'm Turkish and I've
been actually following the uh the
protests uh that are still going on uh
uh in Turkey thank you very much for but
my question is uh about the Arab world
uh I don't see all of the protests as
homogeneous and in particular in some
countries uh the protess have been taken
over by uh uh the Muslim Brotherhood or
other Tendencies which uh well I I I'm a
Muslim too but uh I have uh problems
with their approach and uh many of my
compatriots uh uh woman and both from
the Arab world and from Turkey have some
problem with some of their approach to
woman uh in their interpretation of
Islam could you please comment on
that comment on well I I don't don't see
all of the uh oh absolutely they're not
I mean I I I treated them too
homogeneously and there are certainly
differences among the various movements
uh you notice I didn't mention Libya
very much um and certainly things are
uncertain to say you know uncertain in
Egypt um and You' said something about
women well uh everything is unresolved
some of them have led to the uh prolifer
ation of uh the conservative Muslim uh
Islamic tendency and this has adversely
affected woman sure that would happen I
mean I would imagine that we're going to
see many um variations before we see
anything that we can clearly Define I
mean it is such an open book and so
unresolved that I would be really
foolish to make some prognosis or
whatever I mean I think it was it was
almost a foregone conclusion that the
Brotherhood would come to power um and
and I'm surprised that hasn't happened
more clearly in Libya than it has and
I'm surprised that it started to happen
and didn't happen in Tunisia although
that's still a little a little touchy um
certainly we can't we we can't talk
about all these insurrections as one
thing but I'm just trying to point to
the elements that we can see that are
different from what we've seen before um
and how that will pan out in terms of
gender relations also remains to be seen
I mean one of the papers this morning
stressed the uh sexual assaults in Egypt
but
um that might be that might be a
minority set of of events uh so I'm not
sure that we should think of of these
revolutions or sorry these insurrections
as necessarily bringing out um sexual
assault against women or we might think
that in our patriarchal World in general
that these kinds of mass coming together
of people where there's anger involved
and so on might result in assaults
against women so I don't want to think
of of U of the exceptionalism of Egypt
along these
lines by the way I'm a master of not
answering questions
directly I don't really mean to do that
but I realize I have that tendency this
is not a direct question yeah no well uh
Fatima sadiki I am I belong to uh the
University of Fez Morocco but I'm also a
full bride
uh currently full bright at the
University of what is it
called pona in
California I listened to every word you
said really fascinated me I admire your
courage to try and encapsulate all that
theoretically maybe a lot of people in
our part of the
world in different um disciplines and
from different perspectives
understand that maybe it's too early but
people I mean people who think about
these things cannot wait they you have
to to think about these things uh you um
you mentioned a lot of things at the
beginning and which I understand and uh
you did more than that you Tred to
actually everything you said at the
beginning you tried to link to to
whatever you
observed my question is um well these
things happened
spontaneously for
some and we understood later on that
things led to other things do you think
that maybe uh the theoretical dilemas
will sort themselves out later on no no
that's you said you don't answer
directly okay okay then yeah yeah let me
change my wording maybe no maybe no okay
that's that that's indirect enough yeah
but I am I'm also interested in these
things so do you think that these things
that was my first query will simply
change or don't you uh think that the
movements themselves change not not not
that they're heterogeneous in addition
to being
heterogeneous you start with one thing
and you end up with other things we had
a
milder Arab Spring in Morocco but a lot
of things came from it so I just want
your take on
this no I you know I was thinking uh of
marusa and the continuing
Revolution and even though marusa was in
you know writing in an entirely
different framework a Marxist framework
but a kind of neo-marxist framework um
nonetheless that that expression had you
know stayed in our language and um and I
think to some extent that's that's what
we're seeing now uh even though you know
we're hesitant to use this word
revolution but maybe we can use it
Loosely and say that we're well as
deashi said you know this is a work in
progress this is a continuing he said
continuing Revolution and and that's how
I view it I I wouldn't be at all
surprised to see all of these areas go
through many different uh stages I mean
in Egypt the Muslim Brotherhood could
come to power again and and so on um and
probably not I mean probably we're going
to see what we saw in Algeria sort of um
suppression of the of the Brotherhood
and then you know constant tension and
an unresolved uh situation because of it
I that would be my
guess very quickly but what we what's
the impact of of that on the the on
Theory
itself theories of what they are they
also change yeah they are what they are
and they also change and I suppose it is
changing our theories I mean that's what
I was basically talking about that we do
have to look at these things differently
and that it's as you said earlier it's
probably too soon to be able to say uh
very definite things about
theoretically uh but we
can
yeah hi my name is Han I'm a Prof
professor in um IB zor University in
Morocco um in fact the uh the point that
you have raised about the slowness of
change uh I mean it raised a lot of
questions in my mind since I'm dealing
also with the question of the Kota
system in Morocco the Kota system so
these are some measures that are imp
implemented in Morocco and these are
kind of top down and I'm I'm just in um
asking the question what kind of changes
are we looking for for because these uh
when we when we look at change and it
comes too
slow it's not enough but when we look at
other types of changes in the region
also and they come too abup abruptly and
too uh fast then it's not okay also
which is which is something because I'm
going to discuss this also because it's
a problem what kind of changes are we
looking uh at at this region uh how can
we um uh reach the the good results of
having human rights and having uh
women's rights in uh in particular uh
fulfilled in a in a satisfying way if we
can say thank
you well I suppose it depends on what
region we're talking about what region
within the region I I guess it depends
on what level of change we're talking
about I mean are we I mean you you said
top to bottom whatever what kind of
change um and so I don't think I can
that that I maybe you can but I don't
think I can make a a sweeping uh
statement but I certainly do believe in
whittling away at a Grassroots level I
mean you know when I look at the world
and and get depressed about you know
say the US ruining Iraq and little
things like that I want to crawl under
the bed and I do crawl under the bed and
I stay there for a day or two and then I
remind myself that I only have to do
something wake up that morning and do
something
little um and and that's what keeps me
alive and keeps me moving is just this
idea that we sometimes we just have to
whittle away um do little Grassroots uh
Grassroots is not always little but you
know work at a Grassroots level and that
is
slow but it seems to me that if there's
a lot of Grassroots activity as there is
in sedan right now um
that people are not really may not be
paying attention when actually something
very big is
happening and and that's so you've got
you know sort of simultaneous things in
a sense uh the potential at least uh for
for great change um yes
Wern Western you want to S uh have a
look at the whole picture the the notion
of wholeness what I say I mean uh
recently in Morocco we have political
representation of women I mean if we
look at the percentage maybe we can say
it's it's okay we have the picture the
picture is great it's is um um peret as
we say perfect but if we look at the
details then we are going to see that
the the picture is not it's just
fabricated and that is the that is the
problem of change what kind of changes
are we looking for when it comes too
slow it's it's problematic but also when
it comes uh with with intervention with
specific measures it's also too
problematic I
agree I would also appreciate um some
thoughts from the sanist in the group
too
to
hi my name is Neil uzun sociology PhD
student at rkers uh I'm from turkey and
I agree with most of the things that you
just said and conceptualize about all
these movements uh all the fluidity and
cinity you know performativity like
postmodern Notions of um let's say all
these like fluid Dynamic ideas um but
the part that I'm a little bit
suspicious is that when the gizm
movements happened in uh turkey
everybody was uh let me use the term
romanticizing this almost New Politics
and saying that oh we found each other
and oh like we found this new mode of
doing politics together it was so
interesting for us but then again there
was this all historical moments of
feminism revolutionary students M and
leftwing organizations and they were
saying that we were already here and
this is actually how you know about
let's say using uh lemon on your eyes
for tear gas because teargas was first
used in the mid 90s for uh student
movements that were mobilized by
revolutionary let's say fractions of
left parties and also considering the
fact that um the majority of the people
who died during this protest were from
other white neighborhoods mostly once
again U mobilized by revolutionary left
fractions so my question is that how can
we incorporate this notion into this
postcolonial understanding as if almost
saying that this you know let's say
traditional Marxist Ms traditional
feminist movements were not almost as
not there but now we have this new mod
because I think this new mode of doing
politics might be only valid for certain
class and certain groups of people let's
say so in in that sense my question is
that how would you incorporate this idea
that uh these kind of changes and
movements might already be built on
previous modernist Frameworks yeah
that's a really really really fine
statement um and I think a a valid uh
criticism of of the paper um and I I
would sum it up to some extent to say
that the paper is
ahistorical um and that no thanks that
helps me a lot because um I mean I I'm
someone who there was a paper earlier
this morning and I can't remember whose
I'm sorry but um where we talked about
oh someone asked probably uh someone
asked about trade unions and I know that
Joel banan has made a very strong uh
statement about how it was really the
trade unions that made the difference in
Egypt with the trade unions hadn't come
in the toppling of Mubarak would not
have happened at least at that moment
and um and that we you know that we have
not paid enough Credence to these uh to
these previous uh uh mov movements and
ideas and that sort of thing so I think
you're you're quite right in your
correction of not not romanticizing and
not going too far with this with this
notion of the the new ingredients and
new way of of but what I I what I'm
hoping is that these will be in ideas
that will be inserted into uh let's say
broader movements because I'm not I'm
not a post-modernist I may have sounded
like it
but uh but I'm not I just like to play
with the ideas because I think we've
been closed for too long the marxists
have been you know Marxist parties at
least have been pretty closed uh pretty
stultifying which is word I used earlier
and I'm I'm just trying to I gave this A
variation of this paper in sedan to a
mainly communist audience which was a I
I considered it to be a severe critique
of the Communist Party
um and they did not miss the fact that
it was a severe critique uh the men
objected to the some of the ideas the
women embraced them which was very
interesting to me I think women saw it
as a as as some of these ideas is
creating more openings for them and so
we might want to look at that too but
thanks and I really liked your paper
this
morning the Arty part of
me hi my name is is n and I'm from the
University of Southern California and
you just said that your paper was a
historical but if I was I was wondering
given that Egypt saturates the media and
has historically um and given Egypt's
relationship with the Sudan um is there
is was there a special relationship
between Egypt and the Sudan um from my
research in Egypt a lot of it was from
Tunis and uh it was cross regionally but
is there a specific relationship because
of the history between between Egypt and
Sudan that uh you know well there is a
close history yes and uh especially with
regard to communist movement for example
but um Amina what do you think about the
the relationship
now Islamic fundamentalism in Sudan
originated in Egypt right through the
the work of s and Hass Al those are the
leaders of the Islamic f
groups and they really they went back to
Sudan and they established the Islamic
regime in Sudan also the Communist party
started in Egypt at the same time um uh
with Henry Corell um the the leader the
the person who established the Sudanese
Communist party and the Egyptian uh
Communist party so there are a
relationship between the two and even
now in the politics of the Communist
Party of Sudan and the other traditional
uh political parties in Sudan they do
have this um
um this different views conflicting
views on Egypt um Unity with Egypt or
against the Egyptian because of the
historical um uh the history of of Egypt
as as they call it an occupi when they
were together with the British and the
Turkish occup in Sudan so I think the
relationship is really strong um even
right now the only regime that really um
stand with Mory is the Sudanese regime
yeah they hosted all the the the the um
the old ministers are visiting Sudan
last last week and the week before there
was there um they have the military
camps there in Sudan um helping the
islamist in in Egypt to tole the um the
military role there so I think it's it's
really they're working together all the
time we always thought that um the
intelligence in Sudan is Egyptian we
never thought that there are Sudanese so
um so they have some kind of
relationship yes thank you um but and I
think that uh the constant reference to
the Arab Spring that I was hearing um
tells us that even even though they may
not be enacting necessarily some of the
the uh um tactics that they're thinking
about it and that it you know that that
if we believe in Contagion Theory uh
certainly uh it it was part of the spark
of uh 200 and 13 would you agree
Amina or
Ellen or
Anita uh I'm smadar Lai I I'm with the
Middle East studies Center in Berkeley
and I'm also the co-founder of Israel's
feminist of color movement or a or in
Arabic
and because of my political work in the
years I was locked up in Israel I
started thinking about the moment when
agency becomes
impossible uh your paper was very
hopeful on the
whole and I'm coming at it from a point
of view not only of activists my kind
but also Scholars who work in the
discipline of world
anthropologies one of the critique of
world anthropologies is that there is a
certain us European grip over the
production of theory and one of the US
European oh us grip over the production
of theoretical knowledge and one of the
key themes particularly in American
anthropology because we are always we
always like to help the little guy is
the whole notion of agency even doile
agency Al Sab Mahmud then the theory com
comes from here it travels to places in
the global South it often times
superimposes itself uh there is
engagement with global South
intellectuals but when it comes to who
do you quote as far as making
theoretical progress it would be maybe
people who migrated from the global
South to the US euro center to produce
that kind of theory or people who are
being cherry-picked from the global sou
let's take for example ashil mebe and
the way that he's been canonized and how
many others have not been canonized say
to the University of Chicago and then
from the University of Chicago uh to get
a leg legitimate C cachier of having
having it be like a global sou theorist
but it always gets filtered through the
US European production machine people
say like junji Kumi or Susan rotski are
very critical of the model of agency
they think it's very benevolent
partially it's because even with
postmodernist incoherence it tries to
create incoherent coherence of theory
that is then being imported to The
Cosmopolitan scholars in the third world
who write for academic journals
here and part of this critique of agency
is when it clashes against baroc
y I haven't seen I've been following the
Egyptian uh Revolution Insurrection from
the point of view of the Sinai bedu and
I still have I've been working there for
40 years and I still have active
research most of their life is spanned
against
monolithic uh non polyic Egyptian
bureaucracy that governs their life and
therefore they have their own islamist
or they call it the bedwin in
uh however for many people all of these
Notions of movement Mobility just to
move to another town is too
costly um and and I wonder how much of
it is our own
doer
radicalism and optimism and romance that
is being imported there and how much
there is an engagement with SE theories
that emanate not in English from locals
in the global South most of which are
not dealing so much with
multiplicities but they're still very
linear because systems of regime
particularly these kind of authoritarian
regimes are very monolithic
still was there a question in there
smart by the way I'm a recovering
Anthropologist I want to I I just want
to put that out there um can you you
want to ask me a question in a s
question is about what happens when we
can no longer work with agency what
happens to our optimism is Scholars and
Scholar
activists what happens in this moment
when Scholars who work not in English
and they not they're not in dialogue
with the major journal in are displ slap
us on our
you always want to help the little guy
we have other theoretical issues that we
write about that you don't read engage
well
certainly I'm what you bring up is so
highly complex that I don't even know
where to start to respond to it except
to appeal to us to be more
self-reflexive uh to be more
self-critical um about what we're doing
and about what I've what I've called um
my migrating epistemologies I've written
about that um the same kind of circular
Pro it wasn't circular exactly but let
me use that word for now circular
process that you describe so
articulately um I don't know what we do
about it uh in the way in which you've
asked the question except to to be aware
of exactly what you said about not you
know about the realization that things
on the ground
um the that the better one are not going
to be using postmodernist ideas and uh I
don't mean to be humorous here um are
not using postmodernist ideas and that
we're in the clouds in terms of of the
way in which we're sending ideas back
and forth I thoroughly agree with you
about um the way in which we we anoint
um Global South Scholars when they have
embraced the ideas that they got from
the west and then and they come to the
west and they become these these Saints
like
BBE um but I don't know what to say
about it at this point um I don't know
how to um how to concretize and how
to play a role as you say what happens
to agency in this kind of
situation um but I'm not going to let
you depress me
thank you so much uh my name is elas
Paya PhD student from University of Fest
uh I would like first to thank you for
your great and valuable lecture thank
you uh I think I would like to join
Madame sadiki in her uh inquiry about
the theoretical Frameworks the the
problem is that uh we have to ask maybe
at this point to what extent the current
theoretical Frameworks and paradigms
that we are using now I'm sorry I'm
missing a word discursive Frameworks is
that what you discursive Paradigm
theoretical that we are using now to uh
analyze and describe and anticipate the
events that are going on in the Arab
Spring the Arab uh world to what extent
they are successful in really making
a a valid uh description and uh an
analysis and anticipation of the event
and at this time we have also to to ask
uh are they are these discri discursive
theoretical Frameworks are they open to
other uh paradigms for example the
Islamic Paradigm and here I would like
to bring about the the idea of gender
equality so how can gender equality be
understood within the Western theortical
framework or in the is Islamic framework
I mean when we talk about equality
within the family how can we understand
it we understand from the United Nations
uh conventions and in comparison or in
contrast with the Islamic Paradigm so
can we make an openness or we can
illustrate on
that well I think
you I think you cautioned and you added
a good point I'm not sure that it
requires a response from me I would hope
that um this if I've presented a
paradigm which I don't think I have I
was a little bit too kg to do
that um but if I've presented a paradigm
then I'd like to think that it's a
paradigm that's open to uh Islamic ideas
for
example thank you s for your um for your
distinguished lecture I I found a couple
of things that you said really U very
interesting to take home with me I mean
I haven't seen the happy dance at afod
on YouTube yet I'll go look for that but
the quot ation of someone saying I don't
even care if the government stays in
power so what I'll just go about doing
what I'm doing I think that's really the
big inspiration for us in a lot of
different movements is to see and
including occupy and some of the others
that you've seen where people are
changing the discourse in pop culture
and spreading it through social media
and other means um I'm I'm just thinking
of how rapidly generational change
actually happens we don't think of
change as being so rapid because our
lifetimes are really short but it's
breathtakingly fast what's happened in
the last 200 years of human history it's
our lifetimes and so I I just really
feel like these um ideas of designing or
intending or planning a certain kind of
change or having a model for how
revolution has to happen and oops it
didn't go that way so we failed I think
that's probably our very limited Horizon
of what we're looking at huge changes
have happened I mean just look what
happened with uh in the United States
with gay marriage in Uganda with gay
issues I mean there things happen really
quickly and we don't necessarily see
them coming and they don't stop where
they are because they get they provoke
backlashes and then something else
happens and I just feel that our
understanding of change hasn't been
sufficiently dialectical and I think
you've raised some ways in which it is
definitely very very complex and
interesting and I've always admired the
way you end everything with questions
you never give us a conclusion or
guidance I that's what I've always
admired answers that's right none and
none of us do and so that's why I really
I feel like you've Pro provoked a very
nice question for us and you probably
have many more to go so thank you very
much for your questions thank you well I
see we have two more minutes before our
coffee break so is there one last
thought or comment for Sandra and her
distinguished lecture maybe she can
provoke us yeah maybe do you want to say
do you have anything that you like
anything anybody want to say one more
pressing thing or Sandra maybe you have
some final thoughts now no just I
thought that there were some very good
comments that I to think about yeah it
was a really um thought-provoking
compelling distinguished lecture I'm so
glad that you're our distinguished
lecturer this year sandre if I hear that
term one more time very distinguished it
was very distinguished anyway why don't
we why don't we thank SRE again and then
take a coffee break
okay